hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff it's the Murphy saga and in
this game we're gonna cover in this
video we're gonna cover again between
Paul Charles Murphy and the Hungarian
master Johann Jakob Blumenthal and in
the previous video of you've seen
morphix game against his father at a
rather young age to see that he was
already able of producing some some good
moves but here Morphy is already 12
years old this match has been played
almost more Morphy almost had his 13
13th birthday so almost almost 13 but
okay he's playing against his first real
opponent so so far okay he's been
beating his father he defeated the army
generals caught that we mentioned he's
been beating his uncle Ernest Murphy and
he's been beating him even blindfold as
since he was 11 he's been beating his
grandpa with rook odd so this is
amorphous first actual opponent now like
I said he's from Hungary but he was
expelled from Hungary in 18-49 and he
only arrived in North America on 29th of
December so prior to New Year's Eve and
he didn't know anyone he didn't know any
friends but people really accepted him
and since he was a known chess master
they took him to a lot of chess playing
sites and they introduced him to a lot
of people so this is how he was invited
to the home of the Murphy's and he was
brought here to the face Paul Paul
Morphy himself although okay in those
days it wasn't really Paul Morphy
himself because here more Murphy is the
Challenger as he is he's the one facing
the master so that being said let's
check out this very nice game so this is
the first game in the match some people
say that there were three games in this
match some people say that there were
two the general consensus is that there
were actually three dates three games in
this match but we are going to cover
that some times later
so morphe opens with E 4 as Hugh really
does with E 5 by 11th all night of 392
f6 and now a night captures on e5 so the
petrov is on the board and this is a
modern approach to the petrov and thank
you for correcting me in my previous
video i often said the new orally
and it's you guy said it's actually New
Orleans so thanks for that
I blame the House of the Rising Sun for
that but ok we have d6 pushing the night
back night of three and now Knight
captures on e4 so pretty much as if we
were watching a game played in 2019
Queenie to Murphy attacks the night with
Queen to e7 defending and now d3 more if
he kicks the knight back Knight of 6 and
now Knight to c3 so it's so it's that
you don't want to capture because you
help black develop and black doesn't
want to capture because he helps white
develop so Bishop to e6 and now Bishop
to g5 by Murphy with h6 and here more if
he captures with rush of characters and
f6 Queen captures and f6 and d4 grabbing
more space in the center as you will
want to develop your light square bishop
so make sense the
open up this diagonal we have c6 by
Leventhal and it is as a move 10 that
the disposition was never repeated again
so we have queenside castle by morphe
and now d5 grabbing also more space in
the center making room for the dark
square bishop to be developed
we have Knight to e5 by Murphy and here
Bishop to b4 and already here
Murphy plays a most interesting move one
modern masters might not even consider
but here morphe plays Knight captures on
d5 now of course if you capture the
night with the pond then Queen b5 check
picks up the bishop and well it's not a
problem you just grabbed a clean pawn
you're good to go
however Leventhal played Bishop capture
son b5 and he said ok I don't mind I
grabbed a piece you can have your Knight
to g6 check this is what more if he
played and now 11th all blocks with the
Queen Queen to East 6 and here we have
Knight captures on h8 so morphe grabs a
rook however after Queen captures any
two bishop characters and came to f8 now
Leventhal a very strong master knows
that two pieces are better than the rook
and here morphe plays a3 now if you if
you absolutely want to play this
position to perfection this is actually
a
good idea by morphe that he decided to
give up two pieces for the rook however
you have to play it a with c4
although asking well asking this is
asking a lot even for modern players
Bishop to e6 d5 see capture sandy five
and now Bishop to f3 where if the pawn
captures or moves you when the b7 point
and the rook so here you would see King
g8 Bishop captures on d5 Bishop captures
rook captures now you cannot capture as
a roof to d8 would prevent black from
ever developing the Queen side Bishop to
e7 preventing this and now Knight
captures on f7 you have to win at least
some material if you're gonna give up
the night king captures and rook to e1
so this is basically playing the
position to perfection you would have
two rooks against the rook Knight and
the bishop but do two rooks are
extremely active and well white is
slightly better here you are up two
points for your for your sacrifice
material more if you played it a bit
differently he played a3 we have Bishop
to d6
and now Bishop to d3 and okay King GI
Leventhal and here Morphy grabs Knight
captures we have King captures and now
f3 not allowing any captures here so
it's basically the same thing more if he
still has two rooks for Murphy still has
a look for two pieces and he's he's up
two pawns but the differences more fees
rooks are not so active and well his
opponent still has the bishop pair so
kb5 by Leventhal and now Bishop the e4
Morphy wants Leventhal to capture so he
can improve his Center Knight to d7
elemental continues developing and now
rook DT one we have Knights to f6
putting pressure on the bishop and now
rook the e2 preparing to bring the other
rook into the game we've looked at eh
and here well mostly
rook H 2 e 1 is of course to be
considered you might even consider it an
automatic the problem is after the shop
characters and F captures you have
Bishop captures on h2 so although you
have a very nice Center if a c4 c3 will
be played you don't want to give up a
pawn as you're already down material so
after rook to e8 Morphy decides for
Bishop captures on d5 with
we have C capture Sun d5 rope capture
sunny a king
sorry knife captures an e 8 and now g3
now the route can get into the game as
there is no bush of Kafiristan H 2 so
here the I find this game very
impressive as this is a more fees first
game ever especially more fees first
endgame ever against a real chess master
so here we have g5 elemental and now
King d2 Murphy brings the King into the
game we have Knight to g7 and now
although the e-file is the only open
file on the board NES rooks do belong
and open files problem is here the the
Bishop Knight and pawn control all of
the squares you can use so all of these
squares are not available to draw so
here morphe please looked a 1 instead
and he prepares a 4 which of course
makes sense with a 5 now preparing to
meet a 4 would be 4 now Murphy improves
the position of the King even further
King d3 we have King e6 11th all does
the same and now a 4 more if he wants to
bust open through the eve of the through
D a file with his rook we have before
and now again with with with absolute
engine precision more figures c4 and
here of course if the capture screen
captures you improve the position of the
King a bit too much
so here the love and tell goes better up
the c7 instead but now rook to e1 check
King d6 now blocking bishops control of
the e5 square and now rookie 5 morphe
now prepares the capture on e5 and now
the DC 4 is is forced Saudi captures and
c14 captures morphe improves the
position of a skink even further and now
Knight the e6 by Leventhal
we have looked a b5 putting black in
sort of a little - kwanghee doesn't
allow the bishop any moves so you have
to you have to play something else
either go back with the night or go back
with the King here 11 took place tonight
back to f8 and only now rogue d5 check
we have king to e6 look to see 5 more
feet puts the rook and c5 now King back
to d6 by Leventhal and now d5 grabbing
even more space
rook the c6 coming with winning of the
h6 pawn so King today
seven not allowing that you will be able
to block with the bishop but now look
the CSEC is just the same
we have Bishop to d6 but now rook the a6
the bishop cannot keep blocking the path
towards DHS exponent also not allow
capture of the a five point so here if
you move the bishop of course you lose
the h6 Ponzo nice the G success plate we
have rook a person 85 by morphine and
now tonight's the e5 with check King to
be 5 and now b3 not allowing this the B
point to be pushed and also Leventhal is
hoping for something like 93 captures
the pawn and then maybe promoting the
b-pawn we've looked a seven by Murphy
with check King to d8 and now F for
pushing the knight back now no longer
allowing even Knight captures on f3 g
Capra's with G captures and now Knight
to d3 going after the beat you pawn but
now kink the c4 attacking the knight
here of course you could capture here
but then just kink after Sun b3 and then
I just kicked away although it does make
sense that the capture here King
captures and then we retrieved with the
night ok 11th all goes Knight captures
an f4 instead and the morphe just goes
rook to h7 there's always time to
capture here and so for the moment your
d5 pawn would be hanging so Russia b5
preparing the character on B to know
more if he captures on h6 rook captures
and h6
we have Bishop CalPERS on b2 and now
King captures on b3
we have Bishop to g7 attacking the rook
rook to h7 and here we have Bishop to e5
as the bishop is under attack so feel
free to pause the video what would you
play here well I'll give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who decided that
kink the c4 is the best move it is
playable but there's no there's no need
to capture Yandy on d5 absolute best is
a five this is what morphe played and
congratulations to everyone who also
decided that a five was best
so King
well now that a five has been played
there's the question why not capture the
point well of course if you capture the
pawn then rock age five simply attacks
to pieces and there is not much to be
done here if you don't capture the pawn
you are up against three points so let's
explore the option if you continue king
c8 you just play a six king b8 now you
go king c4 Bishop to d6 not allowing the
king to c5 but now h4 and now h5 h6 and
you will not be able to keep an eye on
all of the three points so instead
Lowenthal knew that he was lost here he
decided for a knife capture son b5 but
more fee of course played rook to h5 I
only imagined he played it instantly
Bishop captures an h2 but now rook
captures and d5 would check came to see
it and now rook the b5 not allowing the
King to cross the B file King c7 and
here Murphy played a six and it was in
this position unknown 55 that Hungarian
master Johann Jakob Leventhal resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here for those of you who are maybe
new to chess we are just going to play
it out if rush of g1 preventing the pond
to reach a7 King c4
you're gonna go king c6 or something
rugby 7 it's important to guard the a7
square bishop somewhere doesn't really
matter you're gonna move the rook rook
g7 and next move a 7 is coming whatever
black plays Bishop goes back he will
play a 7 now we have to capture and
after rook captures it is of course a
winning endgame for white so of course
11th all nude the nudists and after a
six he resigned the game so this is the
first game of the match morph 11th all
and well I'm sure Lauren thought did not
expect much from morphe but after this
game it's a very interesting to see what
will happen in the next game and how
will 11th hour approach it and we'll
he take it more seriously because here
I was one of the one of the rarer cases
where well not not so much rarer but
here for example it was really enjoyable
for example here at for captures
captures how the rope was completely
dominating the the bishop and the night
there was there was nothing to be done
here especially here after rook to c6
for example well the bishop and Knight
are dominated and the King has just a
free entry into the game but ok it
wasn't just a rook for two pieces for
two minor pieces it was a rook for two
minor pieces and more if it was up two
points that's a big big difference so
now like I said after this a6 move
elemental resigned and a brilliant
victory for Paul Morphy in his first
ever game against a renowned chess
master so we're gonna continue this
match morpha Lowenthal is well into the
series so I hope you enjoyed the game
and it was really really impressive how
Murphy played the endgame he didn't know
any I imagine there were no principles
back then morphe created principles when
he played he didn't know that you know -
two minor pieces are better than rook he
just played the position and in this
position he knew that the rook will be
will be stronger than the two minor
pieces so I find that incredibly
impressive and we're gonna check out the
other game as in the other game xi all
will go for the Sicilian defense so you
know prepare for that sure that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Julien your subs are they
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot - really appreciate it as
usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga and of course following whatever is
currently happening in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day